mr. soya you are the very first family
we've had in the residential section of
the poll after you secured the
assessment when you think of the
building the Pearl is the most advanced
super tall structure in the world it's a
breathtaking achievement but no one
really knows what would happen if things
go wrong because you are known for your
muscles in this film it was so much in
the eyes and I know you talked about
that's right a little bit like when you
go on the crane John that there's that
decision that you make but there's also
an opening shot when they show something
horrible happens and they show up close
with your eyes correct so I wanted to
give you a couple scenarios okay and you
can just maybe camera give me the eyes
oh yeah yes all right I got this one I'm
sure you do it's been three weeks since
you've had your cheap pancakes on Sunday
and they're sitting right in front of
you it's been a month since you've been
at the gym and you see iron you're
running the crane you're doing it you're
doing it now you're not gonna do it
you're stopping you show up on set and
you have a three page monologue
[Laughter]
what does creative or cool thank you you
would think to use duct tape for I've
done like some art projects with time oh
yeah yeah
it helps we get asked to do some crazy
things in preschool now what do you do
so this was your first movie right yes
was it your first movie too Thank You
major
you killed it I've asked everybody in
the cast what is the most cool or
creative thing that you would do with
duct tape
maybe I've actually created a rope with
duct tape and my house maybe yeah maybe
I died deserting building from upstairs
to downstairs
what do you do like are you gonna be the
next spider-man yes we thought be your
goal I mean yeah
[Music]
the rock is known to do is one eyebrow
raised oh you just did it I'm actually
uh embiid dextrous eyebrow you're gonna
give him a run presents pretty good too
yeah yeah you should start the trade
parking yeah I know I'm very talented
you know the rock is known to do a one
eyebrow raise can you guys do it yeah
show the camera show the camera can you
wiggle your eyebrows can you make your
glasses move that's so cool
the fact that he plays that Dwayne plays
an amputee in this film why do you think
that was important because he's just a
regular guy you know it's a regular guy
with a certain disability which is a lot
of us we all have certain disabilities
you know and to overcome incredible odds
to save his family
that's what movies are for we often see
DJ will most often see DJ in films where
you know he's just the hero and
obviously look at him he's gonna he can
do anything he looks like he can do
anything you know so I think having him
play an amputee allows him a
vulnerability that we might not expect
from him and he really pulled it out
like he he there's another level I think
it's great I think he's hilarious and
he's very talented but there's like
another level of acting in this film you
know we live in a time where there is a
great identification and love for
superheroes and larger-than-life
characters and I think that you know we
we just wanted to get real and and bring
it you know back to the everyday man and
someone with that kind of challenge and
with the prosthetic leg which he uses
very ingeniously in the past well you
know I think bringing that you know
keeping it real bringing that back you
know down to earth that's how we want to
connect with the audience you know well
I mean I think skyscraper shows Dwayne
in a way that nobody's ever seen him
before and that's not just about the
missing leg that he plays an amputee
it's a vulnerability all the way through
and what you open with asking about his
eyes that's everything yeah I'm so proud
of Dwayne's performance and audiences
you've seen it did anything it's the
best thing he's ever done
you know he's not invulnerable he's not
a superhero he's a man trying to save
his family and he struggles and it's
bloody and broken and he barely survives
the whole way and it's it's something I
can't wait for people to see because
they've never seen the rock like this
yeah thank you you're welcome
I only meant this much of it though yeah
you guys love different ripping each
other oh it's so easy is it
yeah look at the guy he's a joke you sit
like that you know what I'm an you're
like a cartoon you're like a big smiley
cartoon right there I don't know if that
was real laughs I don't know that laugh
is I'm gonna I'm gonna talk weird and
talk about this later
I'm gonna talk about
[Music]
you